good morning John this morning I got up
checked Twitter tweeted about my
halitosis kissed my cat brush my teeth
got in my car filmed some scishow got
some p4a perks ready to ship went back
home tumbled made a video for Hanks
channel molested the kid II went out to
the warehouse with Catherine folded mud
boxes because I love folding mud boxes
made a video for the dftba records
channel then came home edited an episode
of hank games live tumbled some more
lonesome money through Kiva and then I
made a vlogbrothers video I haven't
actually made the vlogbrothers video yet
that last part was a lie tell you that I
made for Hanks channel was sort of like
a walkthrough of all of the vlogbrothers
designs since late 2007 and archives
first archive of the Bob brothers
YouTube channel was December 1st 2007 11
months after we started making videos
and we had just under 10,000 subscribers
and that was a huge deal we've been
making videos for a long time and we
were very proud of that number it was
really amazing and yes this is what that
looked like four by three Oh actually
yeah that's it this is this is more haha
on the day that we hit 10,000
subscribers we also launched the first
project for awesome we thought that our
community was so big on YouTube that it
was a shame that we were not using it to
do some good in the world people do not
feel that way about 10000 subscribers an
email private for awesome however was a
huge success that year and it has been a
huge success every year since this year
we raised over four hundred thousand
dollars and finally I get to tell you
who's gonna get that money sorry this
took so long but it turns out that
you're getting a lot of money away it
gets complicated legally dumb we have
the office of letters and light not
forgotten the wildlife Waystation the
Alzheimer Society the Harry Potter
Alliance Save the Children the BGSU
dance marathon uncultured project techo
and love 146 Dayton task force and all
those charities for doing such great
work and thank you to the people who
make videos to support them obviously
for me the big thing hanging over this
video is that we got a million
subscribers this week and we also got
300 million video views on vlogbrothers
and with the help of you if you would
like to help we would also like to hit a
third milestone this week and that is
reaching 2 million dollars loan through
Kiva orgs nerd
a group were very close we're like 1.97
$6,000,000 the other current gout you
may have twenty five dollars or even
more than that just sitting there ready
to loan and if you don't have a current
account is linked in the description
probably your first twenty five dollars
loaned will be free donated for you to
loan out now somehow despite the fact
that having a million subscribers is
obviously a huge deal and is very
important to me and it feels totally
impossible at the same time when I think
back to what our channel was when we had
ten thousand subscribers I feel about
the same about this project now as I did
then maybe that's because to some extent
these videos have always been and
remained just videos that I'm making for
my big brother maybe it's because we've
always been very open about who we are
and how we live our lives while still
being entertaining so people don't get
the wrong idea about us being more than
we are or maybe it's because this
community is just a one-of-a-kind never
to be seen again kind of thing and in
any case I'm very happy that that's how
I feel so thank you to everyone who's
been a part of this over the years
whether you started watching when I was
giving away peeps on the street in 2007
or when I was translating dance songs in
2013 thanks for watching and finally a
little bit of research that I want to do
in the comments please I'm curious what
was the first vlogbrothers video you
watched and when was that
I understand if you don't remember I
remember what my first vlog but this
video I watched was it was the first one
before anyone outside cuz I made it I
was the first person to watch a vlog for
this video
hipster I was watching vlogbrothers
videos before it was cool also so are
you you are right now watching
vlogbrothers videos before it's cool
hopefully it will never be cool John
I'll see you on Tuesday
[Music]